so the other day a friend and I went to
go get a pretzel and then this happened
I'm sorry I asked for a salted pretzel
Oh were closing in 15 minutes so I'd
have to take the butter out of the
fridge okay it's just that this is a
plain pretzel which is gross I'd have to
take the butter out of the fridge then
we went to Joanne's fabrics and the same
shit went down I can't ring this up you
have to go back to that other counter
where you were waiting for 20 minutes
before you gave up and came here it's
store policy uh can't you just charge us
for the whole thing I mean we're ready
to pay for the whole thing okay
store policy look I get that this is
probably a day job for you you have
other dreams and aspirations that don't
involve working with wieners or fabrics
but what you're basically saying to me
right there is I just don't give a fuck
and all you have to do to get what you
want is say it like a helpful person oh
I'm so sorry we actually just put that
away it's sort of like closing procedure
it's a whole thing I'm sorry oh okay
yeah no problem don't worry about it cuz
I'm good reasonable you know I've seen
the butter fridge I don't know what that
but when you do that thing where you
throw your hands up in the air like it's
some act of God that's preventing you
from helping me instead of your laziness
as a person what I really want to say to
you is wow thank you so much oh valued
employee of this company you know I
can't recall ever receiving such amazing
and helpful customer service Wow
much appreciated great job here here are
all the folks
you're not giving cuz I believe it
doesn't matter what you do or where you
are how you approach one thing is
probably how you approach everything so
have some pride in doing your job have a
work ethic that translates to everything
because if you don't we'll see you next
week
stay awesome Gotham